again welcome to fox news primetime
[Music]
i'm jesse watters every week we tell you
how bad crime's getting in america
and every week the situation only gets
worse
but what did we expect that's what
happens when you take away police and
let the criminals run
wild this weekend chicago had its most
violent weekend
of the year with over 45 shootings that
left
six people dead and 74 others injured
how's the city responding to that
by barely mentioning it the headline in
chicago tonight
is that they fired the police officer
who shot an armed suspect back in march
so good luck with that chicago streets
there certainly sound a lot safer
tonight
it was also a violent weekend here in
new york city 23 people shot
two people dead one of the victims was a
21 year old marine
hit by a stray bullet in what used to be
one of the safest spots in the city
times square this marks a second
shooting there in recent months
and the data speaks for itself crime is
totally out of control
and it's the democrats fault they
defunded the police
eliminated cash bail emptied the jails
and hired crooked district attorneys who
let just about everything
slide got a problem with that too bad
aoc says you need to calm down
and put it all in context
we are seeing these headlines about
percentage increases
now i want to say that any amount of
harm is unacceptable and too much
but i also want to make sure that this
hysteria you know that this doesn't
drive a hysteria and that we look at
these numbers in context
so that we can make responsible
decisions about what to allocate
in that context so democrats are willing
to admit
violent crime is unacceptable but it's
certainly not their fault
they have a brand new talking point
blame republicans
let's talk about who defunded the police
when we were in congress last year
trying to pass
a rescue plan i'm sorry not the rescue
plan but
an emergency relief plan for cities that
were cash strapped and laying off police
and firefighters
it was the republicans who objected to
it so look republicans are very good at
staying on talking points of who says
defund the police but the truth is
they defunded the police a lot of
democrats who
supported and voted for the bill could
help ensure
local cops were kept on the beat in
communities across the country
as you know didn't receive a single
republican vote
james craig's the former police chief of
detroit he's been pushing back on the
democrats anti-police agenda every step
of the way all right james it's clear
crime's gotten more brazen it's
happening in broad daylight in touristy
parts of town
and it's the same people every time the
same trigger pullers
they're out on bail and they're out on
parole because they have soft sentences
what's the democratic party's plan to
stop it because i don't really hear
anything
there is no plan jesse i got to tell you
when i listen
to the plan it just scratches the
surface
it's more of the same but they failed to
mention
the key issues this bail reform
is killing the major cities nobody wants
to hold the courts responsible
and let's face it they're public
servants too no one wants to hold the
prosecutors responsible
their public servants so and then
they have the nerve to turn around and
say crime is up
because of police i was ashamed when i
heard
a colleague of mine from los angeles
sheryl dorsey
make the statement that the police are
abandoning their posts because they're
cowardly and she used some other term
that i'm not familiar with
that's not true jesse these men and
women and i can speak to the men and
women in detroit who do a
phenomenal job despite the anti-police
rhetoric
they're facing dangerous suspects every
single day
they're being shot at they're being
attacked but despite that they go
out and serve with distinction and honor
and of course when we see a a george
floyd type situation
that doesn't represent the vast majority
of the men and women then you've got a
mirror out in chicago
who makes it seem as if the police are
dangerous
what message is she sending i got to
tell you
the profession is in crisis jesse it's
in crisis
and nobody is standing up and talking
about it well you've seen a wave of
retirements and
that's pretty much the only thing you
need to know when it comes to the
feelings of these police officers who as
you said
are putting their life on the line all
day to protect the very people that the
democrats claim
they care about you mentioned chicago
they had more people die of
gunshot wounds in chicago last week and
then covid 19.
think about that there were zero covades
in the entire state of illinois and
there were about seven people shot dead
just alone
in the city of chicago if that's the
kind of context
aoc is looking for well then
congresswoman there you have it right
there
where's the outrage jesse you're talking
about children
last count i had 52 children
or young adults 15 years and under
killed since the beginning of the year
where's the outrage and then what you
hear with this new crime strategy we
want to focus on the gun it's not the
gun
let's focus on the criminal it's
criminals who have
gotten access to guns illegally
and they're committing crimes this is
not about gun control
that doesn't work look i've been a long
time advocate
that law abiding citizens should be
armed and now when you talk about
defunding the police
and in some of these cities there's
their police staffing is reduced
who's going to protect law-abiding
citizens
and so of course they should be armed
and it will have an impact on reducing
violence
i've said it and i continue to say it
yeah the best way to get guns off the
street is to get the guys
squeezing the triggers of those guns off
the street in
illinois it's three to seven years
illegal possession of a firearm but they
don't prosecute it
and that's the problem all right james
craig thank you so much prosecute
i know you gotta go i do thank you jesse
all right
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else